[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday April 16th
friendly brotherly reminder your taxes
are due tomorrow
Hank unfortunately I wasn't able to
attend any of the step it up rallies and
I'll tell you why instead of protesting
carbon consumption I was myself
consuming carbon on a series of
airplanes trying to get from San Antonio
Texas to New York City I eventually got
home but unfortunately by then all the
step it up rallies were finished I did
however make a poster I'm not very good
at posters Hank just in case you can't
read my scribbled handwriting my poster
says step it up Congress and also step
it up self because I feel like I'm also
not doing enough in the fight against
climate change and that's why Hank you
may notice that today the video is a
little darker than it usually is it's
because for the next week I'm not going
to be using any kind of electricity that
I don't absolutely have to use the
refrigerator is going to continue to run
my computer is going to continue to run
when I need to use it but I'm not going
to use lights unless they're necessary
as reading lights in the evening and I'm
not going to watch TV except for a
couple of really important soccer games
I'm also going to minimize my use of hot
water which is extremely difficult
because as you know I like to take baths
Hank throughout the week I'm going to be
doing things to further reduce my carbon
emissions let me know if you have any
ideas oh and by the way I loved your
Eagle geek podcasts and look forward to
more of them need to be careful not to
cut off the beginning of your sentences
guess what I got this weekend at the
Texas Library Association convention oh
yeah how awesome is this shirt Hank it's
so awesome that when I looked on the
Haines tag in the back it said that it's
made out of 80% cotton 10% polyester and
10% awesome thanks to Laura pictured
here delivering the shirt Hank
unfortunately there's only one
nerdfighter shirt and I don't want you
to be deprived of its awesomeness so I'm
going to propose a custody sharing
arrangement I'm going to send you the
shirt now and then maybe you can send it
back to me
around June or something and then I'll
send it back to you and you'll send it
back to it's gotten like the Brotherhood
of the Traveling shirt after all Hank
what is Brotherhood if not sharing
clothes remember we always need to share
close growing up remember that sailor
suit that mom made us I was cool I was
really cool man no wonder we were nerds
and finally Hank I know this isn't
necessarily a political video blog but
there is some very exciting political
news going on right now and I can't help
but share it with you our resident
mathematician Daniel Biss is running for
state representative in the state of
Illinois we're going to have a resident
state representative he'll be able to
pass legislation that's helpful to
brothers and nerds and beeps and video
blogs his two most important issues
raising the amount of funding we spend
on education in Illinois which is the
49th state in terms of education thank
God for Mississippi and also cutting
carbon emissions speaking of cutting
carbon emissions I should shut off this
video camera Hank I'll see you tomorrow
Oh PS to make this sign I used recycled
paper this is a page from my book Hank
which I'm just beginning to seriously
revise that process is going to take
several months so expect me to be kind
of moody until say September